[Applause]
[Music]
unless you've been living under a rock
you will have realized that migration is
a hot button topic these days but have
you ever wondered
which country has the most migrants and
proportion to their population what
would happen to a country that has a
population that saved
85 migrants if you think that's just a
hypothetical question
you'd better think again
[Music]
enter the united arab emirates or the
uae a country where just over 12 percent
of its citizens
are actual emiratis yeah really right
now
seven out of eight people in the uae are
not even emirati and it's not just the
uae that's like this
only 15 of the people living in qatar
are qatari citizens this means
that in places like doha the capital of
qatar there are more indians than arabs
believe it or not
this isn't at all uncommon for arabian
gulf countries in fact
every single one of them except for oman
and saudi arabia has a majority
of foreigners depending on the country
the foreign population is between
30 and saudi arabia to 88 as is the case
in the united arab emirates these are
countries with the highest foreigner to
national inhabitant ratios
in the world
as a comparison the usa a country with a
long history of immigration and where
immigration is an
even more hotly debated topic today it
has foreigners making up less
than 15 of its population so
how did this happen are the arab
countries simply a bastion of liberalism
and
tolerance opening their doors to
whatever foreigner would like to live
and work there is it perhaps that these
pious countries feel a moral obligation
to accept refugees from the countless
war-torn countries
of the world well no no not at all you
see
the reason these countries have so many
foreigners is because their economies
are completely
dependable
how dependent well almost the entire
private sector including the oil
industries in these countries is made up
of foreign workers
and no we are not exaggerating for
example at the beginning of 2020 only
five percent of employees in the private
sector in kuwait were kuwaiti nationals
with foreigners making up
95 of the sector in 2018 the uae a
country with over a million citizens had
fewer than 40
000 of its own citizens employed in the
private sector another consequence of
this situation is that most of these
countries domestic consumption is done
by foreigners
as you know here in visualpolitik we're
always talking about the economic
benefits of immigration
but when your whole economy depends on
migrants then you start having a problem
and this
is exactly what has happened in 2020
with the coronavirus pandemic
check this
expats leaving dubai is bad news for the
economy
bloomberg june 2020. migrants and the
gulf come and go
and this is a threat to their whole
production and consumption system so
if that's the problem what would be the
solution many of these countries are
trying what they call
arabization policies which doesn't just
mean that they get really good at making
coffee and smoking cigarettes in kuwait
they call it kuwaitisization in qatar
they call it quaterization and
well there's an isation policy for each
country you get the idea what this means
is they want to make their economies
based on their own national workforce
and get their own citizens into the
private sector so they don't have to
rely on people who can just
up and leave and so they also have jobs
for all their citizens
when all that sweet sweet dinosaur juice
is gone so
how did these countries become like this
and can they really arabise their job
markets
today we're going to answer all of these
questions but before we do
let's have a look at a little bit of
history
can't someone else do it many of these
countries are facing extremely similar
issues and have very similar economic
histories so let's just take
qatar as an example qatar was once
impoverished but
oil and particularly gas was discovered
in the early 20th century and in the
1980s
thus they went from poor to having the
world's highest gdp per capita in just a
few decades
think about it this way back in 1980
qatar had one of the smallest
populations in the world
just 200 000 people then again they have
the third largest gas reserves
on the planet there was plenty of gas
money to go around and
so it did but there was a catch so you
have this extremely poor country with
few universities and almost
no engineers to work in the gas industry
besides the laws are
extremely conservative so much so that
to this day they still have laws against
[Music]
witchcraft
but extracting gas requires a lot of
which is no
i'm kidding it requires high end
technology even more specialized if you
take into the account that qatar needed
to turn its gas into liquid so that it
could be transported in ships
this technology to create so-called
liquefied natural gas requires highly
skilled workers without them there is no
way you can make a profit from your
natural resources
so you see the problem right this is how
qatar started hiring foreign workers
like there was no tomorrow by 1980 the
oil companies were mostly nationalized
but
often had westerners handle things like
management and engineering
[Music]
then they started hiring south asians
from developing countries like india or
bangladesh to take the blue collar jobs
replacing the actual native arabs
so much so that by 2000 just 20 years
later the population had almost
tripled largely through migration by
2020 the population was nearly 3
million people
and now you might be thinking but grant
don't these countries have reputations
for being extremely strict islamist
states how could it be that they would
welcome so many foreigners with almost
all of them being either christian
hindu or buddhist how could they put up
with having two-thirds of their
population
non-muslim enter the double standard
it turns out that there's one set of
rules for nationals and another
for foreigners yeah that's right
for example if you're an american expat
and you want to buy beer and qatar
you can it won't be cheap but it is
feasible that's because most of the laws
prohibiting alcohol
only apply to nationals but foreigners
like me are exempt thank god even
christian churches are allowed in these
countries so
i guess thank him again pope francis
himself paid a visit to abu dhabi in
and by the way we've covered that video
in a visit that i'll link for you in the
description below
hashtag bring back simon as long as they
don't make any attempts to convert
muslims they are good to go in fact in
some of these countries there are entire
venues
only for foreigners where islamic laws
simply do not apply western expats can
keep their lifestyle in nice residential
areas that include gyms
clubs and even international schools
they quite literally segregate the
expats from the rest of the population
at least as much as is possible
when your expat population makes up the
vast majority of your country now
this may sound bad but if you think
about it this is the way these countries
manage to keep their traditions
while co-existing with the rest of the
expats so
overall things kind of worked the arabs
needed educated westerners and
cheap asian labor and the westerners and
asians were happy to oblige
for a cut of that sweet sweet dinosaur
juice money and
they didn't even have to adhere to the
insane local laws
sounds pretty reasonable right well it
may seem like that
at first but many of these countries
have something called the kafala system
what is this cathalla system you might
ask
well the main thing you need to know is
that it is
awful you might even say that it's
modern day slavery this is the system by
which unskilled laborers coming to the
country
need to first be sponsored in order to
be let into
the country this sponsor usually their
employer is responsible for the migrants
legal status and is a dynamic that is
very easily abused
this means that in the best case
scenario you can't do
any other job than the one given to you
by your sponsor and that your sponsor
can fire you and have you kept out of
the country
at a moment's notice in the worst case
scenario you're basically
enslaved you have your pay withheld your
passport confiscated and are subjected
to a myriad of abuses
and there is nobody to help you just
check out this relatively
mild case of abuse
[Music]
qatar little progress on protecting
migrant workers
since august 2019 i've been waiting for
the money said a 34 year old
engineer who went to labor court over
seven months of unpaid wages and who has
been borrowing money from friends in
qatar human rights watch
2020. so by now you can see that this is
pretty bad
and we may be picking on qatar here but
it happens in most of the gulf countries
so now you might be wondering given this
horrible kefala system why do poor
migrants
go to gulf countries well as awful as it
sounds for many migrants this is a real
path to wealth many of these migrants
come from very poor communities and are
paid wages
far higher than they would expect in
their home countries when things
actually do go according to plan they
can even use the money they saved in the
gulf and buy a nice property back home
also after mounting international
pressure several of these countries are
planning to replace the kafala system
in the near future but this isn't a
problem just for the foreigners it's
recognized as a huge problem by the
governments of the entire region so why
are the arabs so concerned about all the
cheap labor in fact where are the arabs
in this equation if it seems that their
entire economy
is run by expats
selling the means of production if you
were to look only at the private sector
of these countries you would think that
their local population was almost
non-existent it would seem like it had
been simply dissolving since the 1970s
or maybe you would just think that
none of the locals have jobs
[Music]
but that's just the private sector data
in fact most of the nationals
are employed as civil servants what this
means is that if you walk into a private
bank in the uae
you would expect almost all of the
employees to be foreigners but the
second you stepped into a government
post office
it would all be nationals it might sound
a little odd at first that there's such
a stark divide between nationals
and foreigners public and private
sectors and it gets even odder when you
look into it you see
this is a system we could call socialism
with arab characteristics
so what do we mean by that well you see
these countries get almost all of their
revenue from the oil industries
these countries then redistribute it to
their national population but not
through
ubi or universal basic income but
through cushy government jobs
that's right the governments of these
countries basically just create jobs so
they have an excuse to pay the nationals
something
of course civil servants do their jobs
but
their conditions are much more
comfortable than the rest of the workers
they don't have to meet any
strict work schedule and there are few
and any efficiency controls
then there are other benefits such as
extra holidays
and the salaries are pretty good in some
cases a civil servant in qatar can make
a base salary of more than nine
thousand dollars sounds pretty nice
right you hire foreigners to do all the
dirty work and then give your citizens
cushy desk jobs
what could go wrong well quite a lot
actually
[Music]
the first and most obvious issue here is
that it's all built on oil money
and only oil and gas money that means
that when the oil starts drying up
like it's doing now things are going to
get
bad this is exactly the problem that
saudi arabia has now but many other
countries such as kuwait and bahrain are
facing similar issues
and if you cannot solve this problem
eventually you have to lay off workers
saudi arabia a country with a very young
population reached a point of saturation
where they simply couldn't hire any more
people in the public sector
this explains why the youth unemployment
rate went up to around 27
and stayed there for those that might
not know that's pretty high
as a comparison the uk's youth
unemployment rate is around 12
so what is being done about this is
anything
being done about this and will any of it
work
let's take a look
hire a local remember the qatarization
saudi ization
all the ization policies i mentioned
earlier the gulf countries are trying
hard to make private companies hire
locals well it is
sort of working sort of check this out
[Music]
101 increase in emiratis recruited in
private sector this year
khalid times 2018.
bahrainization a creeping success in
private sector golf insider 2018. now
despite the good news many of these
numbers are lip service which raises the
question
what are they doing exactly there are
some common approaches just about all of
them have tried promoting technical
studies connecting locals who want to
work with businesses
and setting quotas despite the
commonalities each country is taking a
somewhat different approach
for example in kuwait they tried a
system of subsidies in which a company
would receive government subsidies to
hire their nationals
since most of these countries have
little or no taxes there are not so many
tax benefits they can give
so in kuwait the government gives you a
sum of money for each kuwaiti citizen
you hire
the result
[Music]
great numbers on paper but no real jobs
many of these businesses had ghost
workers and had people on the books who
didn't really work there in order for
the company to get free government
checks
it was such an issue that the program
was eventually rolled back bahrain went
with a strategy that was more stick than
carrot
in fact it was almost the opposite of
kuwait's bahrain actually made laws
about how many employees needed to be
nationals and began finding companies
that didn't hire bahrainis they also
passed laws banning certain jobs from
being taken by foreigners meanwhile
raising the minimum wage for bahrainis
[Music]
for example bank staff must be 50 locals
fashion stores 30 but construction
companies get away with just a tiny
five percent the result well it sort of
worked but it may also exacerbate
bahrain's chronic economy-wide
inefficiency and low productivity
nevertheless
if there's one country with a huge
problem with hiring local workers it is
saudi arabia despite having just 30
of their population coming from
different countries this 30 percent
sustains the entire productive economy
this is not only an economic issue
but it's a cultural one too
[Music]
the idea of labor being done by
foreigners is so ingrained into their
culture that many saudis are just
unwilling to work when it comes to
manual labor or service jobs and this is
exacerbated by the fact that many of
them are not educated technically sure
most saudis go to university but instead
of studying engineering or finance
most of them go for things like islamic
theology islamic studies or arabic in
this type of education
seldom meets the skills required by a
startup
[Music]
this issue can be found across the gulf
but it is especially banned in saudi
arabia so
basically many arabs are unwilling to do
any blue-collar job
why would they when they can just hire a
migrant but when it comes to
white-collar jobs most of them lack the
skill required to do those either this
is important because it shows that this
is as much
an issue of culture as it is of policy
and economics the issue
is not an easy one to fix and if it's
not properly remedied it will be
a disaster after all this is an
important aspect of these countries
shifting their economic model away from
a dwindling resource if no local citizen
can be hired by a private business
how can you expect them to start
businesses on their own
[Music]
this isn't just an issue it's the issue
for these countries and if they don't
solve it soon the
outcome could be disastrous so now
the question is over to you can the arab
nations kick their dependence on foreign
labor could they actually have healthy
economies a century from now and what
would the
ization be for your country leave your
answer in the comments below
as always we really hope you enjoyed
this video please hit like if you did
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos
also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not my dolls at tones finally
this channel is sponsored because of
patreon
and our patrons on that platform please
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage
and as always i'll see you next time and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there